oh look we got a little octopus up in  the car awarded after all those sea pigs  all right Dumbo get one more shot with  the lasers here radiator brace the iris  went down a little bit I think yeah  I'm trying to expose for the oh my god  we need to add a little feather showing  off here you're going to be famous  that's beautiful  I can see it Ripple that's great I told  mantle there well this is great  oh there I love me a good cephalopod the  genus on this is grandpa - 'this grandpa  - this grumpy creatures oh we've only  got another 30 seconds or so  unfortunately every single tomorrow we  may have a GoPro Awards  all right I gotta move along  unfortunately  goodbye goodbye for now your poor soul  to meet you bye buddy hope you find  [Music]